this video is kindly brought to you by
masterworks find out more later
hey 42 here when cambridge university
professor of mathematics godfrey hardy
received a letter from a clerk working
at the port of madras in 1913. it's safe
to say he was fairly sure someone was
having him on
at first glance the letter had all the
hallmarks of a scam it came from a
far-flung country india
and the author a certain s reminusion
mentioned early on that he was strapped
for cash
rather bizarrely he also listed his age
as being
about 23 but just as the alarm bells
were beginning to ring in hardy's mind
the letter took a turn for the strange
because whoever this s ramanujan was
he claimed to have made some startling
discoveries in the advanced mathematical
fields of infinite series improper
integrals
continued fractions and number theory
these were not terms your average con
artist was likely to be familiar with
and so intrigued hardy read on to
support his claims s ramanujan this
lowly clerk who apparently didn't even
know how old he was had followed his
cover letter with 11 pages containing
120 mathematical theorems hardy
recognized several of the equations from
the work of famous mathematicians
but others
were new to him
and a few looked like nothing he'd ever
seen before in his 17-year career
working in one of the world's leading
institutions for pure mathematics some
of the formulas even appear to be
related to areas of study in which hardy
considered himself to be the world's
leading expert
and yet to his surprise
he found he could hardly follow them
the mathematics on display certainly
looked impressive but the letter was so
damn right weird
that to begin with hardy didn't really
know what to make of it but eventually
after sharing the missive with some of
his esteemed colleagues in the maths
department at cambridge
he was forced to conclude that it was no
fraud whoever this clerk from the port
of madras was
he was a truly exceptional mathematician
as it happens that conclusion was
actually some way off the mark
because the author of the letter
srinivasa ramanujan wasn't merely
exceptional he was quite literally one
of the greatest mathematicians ever to
have lived
now i've got a mystery for all of you
that surveyed an answer for almost a
century why would one of the richest
families in history store almost a
billion dollars of their wealth away in
fine art well there's lots of theories
as to why that might be the case and
maybe we'll never know for sure but we
do know some facts about contemporary
art today contemporary art prices
outpaced the s p 500 by 164
from 1995 to 2021. with numbers like
that you can imagine why the
rockefellers are part of a trend that
continues today where over two-thirds of
billionaires allocate more than 20
percent of their overall portfolio to
art
now
the mystery is
how do you do it well lat i can give you
a concrete answer to
with masterworks
i've talked about them on this channel
before and i think what they're doing is
genius
but some may think it's too expensive to
get access to well i want to put that
notion to rest forget what you thought
you knew about the art market and that
it's reserved for the ultra wealthy in
fact members of the 42 community have
already invested with masterworks now is
the right time to look at diversifying
your portfolio and masterworks is how
i'm choosing to do that and luckily for
you masterworks has provided my viewers
with priority access so go check them
out using the link in the description
and start investing in art today
the fact that we even know his name is a
minor miracle in itself
born in 1887 in humble circumstances in
the indian city of a road ramanujan was
the eldest of five children but only one
of his siblings a brother made it to
adulthood
it was a pretty close run thing for
ramanujan as well at the age of two he
contracted smallpox a deadly disease
that's thought to have killed more than
four and a half million indians between
1868 and 1907. ramanujan survived and
eventually recovered but his health was
never quite the same again growing up at
the tail end of the 19th century
ramanujan was given the best education
british india could offer him
i.e not a very good one
that's probably why school didn't
interest him all that much his mother
even had to recruit a local policeman to
stop promenusian from skipping classes
but these indifferent feelings towards
education changed in high school when
ramanujan was first exposed to formal
mathematics something about the subject
just felt right but before long he'd
exhausted everything that either the
school curriculum or his teachers could
offer him undeterred ramanujan decided
that it was time he took his education
into his own hands at the age of 16 he
managed to acquire a copy of gs cars a
synopsis of elementary results in pure
and applied mathematics it wasn't
exactly a textbook there were no
descriptions or explanations
just page after page of complex
equations
about 5000 in all
the book had been written to help
prepare cambridge university students
for the notorious mathematical tripos
exams amongst the hardest undergraduate
examinations in existence at the time
to someone with no training in advanced
mathematics the book should have been
utterly incomprehensible not all that
dissimilar to trying to read a novel in
a foreign language
but as ramanujan studied the 1000 page
tome day after day week after week
slowly but surely the equations within
began to reveal their secrets to him
by the way as a completely random aside
it turns out that the cambridge
mathematical tripos exams are the origin
of the concept of a wooden spoon being
awarded for coming last in a sporting
event
the term comes from an 18th century
tradition in which the student who
placed last in the tripos was awarded
the now famous booby prize actually
wooden spoons were handed out to
cambridge mathematics students for well
over a hundred years with the last ever
spoon being awarded to the superbly
named cuthbert lempiere hult house in
1909. don't ask me why it's that big i
literally have no idea anyway it's
widely accepted that gs carl's mighty
mathematical tome awakened ramanujan's
latent genius sparking an obsession that
would consume him for the rest of his
all-too-short life more on that later
ramanujan excelled in high school
earning himself a scholarship to study
at college as you might expect from one
of the greatest mathematicians to have
ever lived ramanujan absolutely
obliterated every mass problem put in
front of him during his time in college
the trouble was now that he'd found his
calling all of a subject suddenly seemed
boring to him in comparison as a result
he failed pretty much every subject that
didn't have numbers in it
losing his scholarship in the process
without a college degree ramanujan was
effectively barred from any kind of job
that might interest him so he spent the
following four years working on whatever
mathematical problems tickled his fancy
intellectually it was incredibly
fulfilling but financially
yeah not so much ramanujan was an
independent researcher working on some
of the most advanced mathematics being
attempted anywhere in the world but
equations don't pay the bills no matter
how fancy they are and so he lived in
abject poverty literally struggling to
find enough food to stay alive in 1909
ramanujan took some time out from his
busy schedule of doing maths and trying
not to die of starvation to get married
to a 10 year old girl
now i know what you're thinking
that's
not ideal
but it was normal for such young girls
to be married in india at the time and
ramanujan didn't actually have much say
in the matter with the marriage being
arranged on his behalf
to begin with ramanujan's wife continued
to live with her mother but eventually
the couple moved to madras known today
as chennai with a wife to support and a
home to pay for ramanujan reluctantly
accepted that he was going to have to
get himself a job
and by 1912 he'd secured a position in
the clerical team at the port of madras
the work was easy but ramanujan didn't
mind it left him plenty of time to
concentrate on his research
and that research was beginning to bear
fruit with publication in several indian
journals gaining him recognition and
supporters across madras by 1913 it had
become clear to everyone that
ramanujan's work needed to be seen and
appreciated by a wider audience and
that's how he came to write his now
famous letter to godfrey hardy at
cambridge university
hardy was desperate to meet the young
genius in person and he'd begun making
arrangements for ramanujan to come to
cambridge before he'd even replied to
the letter
but to begin with ramanujan was
reluctant to make the journey
as a member of the brahmian or so-called
priestly caste in india he was subject
to the kalapana taboo meaning that if he
were to cross the ocean to a foreign
land he'd lose his social standing back
at home but in the end the pull of
cambridge proved too much and in the
spring of 1914 he made the monthlong
voyage to england aboard the ss nevaza
leaving his wife behind in madras
it's fair to say that life in england
wasn't without its challenges for
ramunesian there was no questioning his
genius but being entirely self-taught
his methods were completely alien to the
traditionalists at cambridge
then there were the cultural challenges
india may have been under british rule
during ramanujan's lifetime
but the two countries could hardly have
been more different
ramanujan's transition to this new life
was made even more difficult when three
months after his arrival in england a
young sir by the name of gavrilo princip
assassinated archduke franz ferdinand in
sarah haver kicking off a chain of
events that would lead to the outbreak
of the first world war
hundreds of cambridge students and
professors were called up to fight the
university quad was converted into a war
hospital and strict rationing made it
difficult for ramanujan to get access to
enough vegetables to sustain his strict
vegetarian diet
despite these challenges his time at
cambridge was incredibly productive
together with hardy ramanujan made
significant contributions in
mathematical analysis number theory
infinite series and continued fractions
over the course of five years
but the england of the early 20th
century wasn't an easy place for a
foreigner and academia has always
suffered from elitism
as a young indian man of little formal
education ramanujan had plenty of
doubters when he first arrived on these
shores
but as he casually solved mathematical
problems that many of the world's
greatest thinkers confidently believed
to be literally unsolvable even his most
ardent detractors were eventually forced
to accept his brilliance
in 1917 he was elected to the london
mathematical society and the following
year he became only the second indian in
history to be elected a fellow of the
royal society
six months after that he became the
first indian to be elected as a fellow
of trinity college cambridge
but just when ramanujan was finally
getting the recognition he
deserved he fell ill
he suffered with ill health throughout
most of his life as i've mentioned but
this time was different the diagnosis
was tuberculosis but none of the
treatments he was given seemed to do
anything sadly there was a very good
reason for that
these days it's thought ramanujan
actually suffered from a condition
called amoebic dysentery a parasitic
liver infection that was common in
madras at the time
had his doctors recognize the symptoms
for what they were the infection could
likely have been resolved but left
undiagnosed and untreated it was fatal
reminusion spent the final year of his
life back in india with his wife
continuing to work right up until his
death in 1920. he was only 32 when he
passed away
at the time he was already widely
regarded as a truly brilliant
mathematician a genius who'd redefined
the boundaries in almost every area of
mathematics he turned his attention to
and invented several new areas entirely
but perhaps the craziest part of
ramanujan's story is that for all the
acclaim he received during his lifetime
it turns out we didn't even know the
half of it
throughout his life ramanujan kept his
many thousands of discoveries in four
large notebooks like the book that first
inspired him he recorded these theorems
without preamble or explanation in the
form of page after page of equations
it was all excellent work the trouble
was without much in the way of
supporting information it wasn't always
clear what the point of it all was
many of the theorems appeared to be
nothing more than interesting
mathematical facts kind of like two plus
two equals four
only a hell of a lot more complicated
that's probably why much of the work was
left largely untouched in the years
after his death it also didn't help that
his theorems were all recorded without
proofs meaning the majority were
essentially unverified but recent
decades have seen renewed interest in
his work
talented mathematicians have dedicated
entire careers to making sense of
ramanujan's 4 000 or so formulas
almost all of which have now been proven
and it turns out that most of his
apparently pointless theorems
aren't actually so pointless after all
in fact many have been linked to deep
mathematical principles and discoveries
that it would have taken the rest of the
world almost 100 years to finally begin
to understand
to this day nobody's really quite sure
how he did it he simply seems to have
possessed a level of mathematical
intuition that borders on the
supernatural perhaps renowned physicist
freeman dyson said it best when
describing ramanujan's unique brand of
genius as
a sort of magic trick the rest of us
don't understand
many of the areas of mathematics that
ramanujan either advanced or developed
sound pretty meaningless to anyone who
isn't a university-grade mathematician
i.e basically everyone
but the areas of science his work is
still being applied to even today will
be familiar to pretty much everyone more
than a hundred years since his death
ramanujan's remarkable mathematical
discoveries are being used to help us
understand cutting-edge science like
string theory and the properties of
black holes
in my recent video on holo earth theory
i compared the way each generation of
scientists and thinkers builds on the
work of the last to a wall of knowledge
that our species has been scaling since
the days of wooden tools
but that wall analogy makes an
assumption that each generation actually
has access to the cumulative knowledge
that came before it but ramanujan knew
almost nothing about the work of the
mathematicians who preceded him
and he had no formal training in the
field of pure mathematics until his late
20s
which is something that almost all of
the great mathematicians in history had
had on their side
and yet from this lowly starting point
shriver nasa ramonusian changed the
field of mathematics forever making
discoveries we still haven't fully
understood a hundred years later to
think that he was employed as a clerk
until his mid-twenties is mind-blowing
that's like finding the next sir isaac
newton working at burger king
it's tantalizing to wonder what might
have been
had ramanujan being given access to more
complete mathematical education from a
younger age and what he might have
achieved had he not died so tragically
young but perhaps we should simply be
grateful for what we did get because
that was something truly incredibly
special he may not have started out life
on top of humanity's wall of knowledge
but as it turns out that didn't really
matter ramanujan just built his own
thanks for watching